[Music]
so anyways Abraham sends his eldest
servant off to his the place that God
has granted him to find a wife and
interestingly the borders of the
promised land are quite similar to the
current borders of Israel in these are
estimates right based on on the biblical
and I mean that's not a fluke obviously
but it's it's interesting to see the
concordance between these ancient
stories and the present-day world so I
thought that was very interesting and it
shows once again that the past you think
the past is the past but it's not it's
it's still here it's embedded in the
present you know just like the future
and somehow in some ways is folded up
inside the present waiting to unfold the
past is all folded up inside the present
too so anyways the servant goes to the
land that he's been charged to go to and
and he's trying to figure out how in the
world am I going to find a good wife for
Isaac I mean I don't know any of these
people and so he has this little
dialogue that's presented in the form of
a prayer I suppose and he thinks well
I'm gonna go to the place where you
water where people get water and water
the animals and because that's a place
where everyone gathers so that's a good
place to find someone and and it's it's
not a place of fun and lightness and
relaxation and impulsivity it's a place
of life-sustaining work and and he
thinks something like well what would a
decent girl do at a watering place and
he thought well maybe she would offer a
stranger some water and also offer to
water the camels because that would be
brave to approach the stranger and then
generous and then indicative of the
willingness to make an effort and when
you know that a camel I think he took
ten camels was quite a few camels
anyways not just one and that a camel
can drink 20 gallons of water
and Rebecca who was drawing water from
the wet turns out to be Rebecca I was
drawing water from the well which is
hard right because water is heavy and
you have to lift it up and it's ten
camels and so that's like 200 gallons of
water so you know she has to put herself
out a fair bit in order to make this
stranger happy and so that's what
happens and then the servant has brought
along gifts and that sort of thing and
anyways to make a long story short
Rebecca
agrees to come back to come back with
the servant and marry Isaac and so